elon musk had an absolute banner year in
2021 the goat literally one of the best
entrepreneurs and founders of our
lifetime there's plenty of people who
hate him but elon just keeps producing
results after results after results our
boy john here going absolutely viral
yesterday with this tweet elon musk had
a massive year he became the richest
person in the world he was paying the
most taxes ever about 11 billion dollars
of u.s government he hosted saturday
night live he was awarded the time
person of the year tesla is delivering
more cars this year than they ever have
elon and spacex also won a three billion
dollar nasa contract they took eight
astronauts to the iss for nasa and
starlink part of spacex launched about
900 new satellites all of this obviously
got elon awarded the time person of the
year with a real cool photo with a
little light on his face saying maybe
elon is knowing what's going to happen
in the future now of course there are
plenty of people who have complaints
about all of the things that elon's
doing he's doing hard things he
literally is the only american car
company to be built and scaled with any
level of success in the last like 100
years the guy also literally has
launched reusable rockets and is landing
them on drone ships in the ocean but
tesla tesla didn't surpass one percent
share of new car sales until 2018. now
during the first half of 2021 their
share of the all-electric segment of the
auto market is about two-thirds they
literally have revitalized the
conversation around electric vehicles in
america shout out elon musk and tesla
and then spacex founded 20 years ago in
2022 or i'm sorry in 2002 musk wanted to
reach 48 launches of the system in 2021
and they ended up setting a new record
of 31 launches by december's end they
have successfully landed a rocket for
the hundredth time 100 times he's
launched a rocket into space and
re-landed it successfully and they flew
falcon 9 for a record 11 times in
december to cap off the year but my
favorite part is what they did 2021
in the impressive comparison
one they launched 94 of all missions on
flight proven falcon 9 boosters they
carried eight astronauts to the iss for
nasa that's right elon musk built a
company to do what nasa can't do he
literally is carrying the astronauts to
the iss in addition to transporting 28
000 pounds of critical cargo and
scientific research to and from the
orbiting lab they completed the world's
first all-civilian astronaut mission the
world's first all-civilian astronaut
mission we ain't going to fake space we
ain't going to the edge of space he
literally sent them to space and they
orbited the earth they also launched
humanity's first planetary defense test
to redirect an asteroid literally there
are people hating on elon musk spacex
but they are out here protecting the
earth trying to redirect asteroids with
a planetary defense test and then of
course they've got the starlink
satellites that i think is going to
bring that high speed low latency
internet to everyone around the world
it's pretty damn cool when you see this
and so if you go ahead and we look at
elon musk's rank on the world's richest
list he started out in 2012 at 634th and
he slowly moved up the list but in 2019
he was only at the 32nd richest person
in the world now he stands atop the
mountain at number one john
you're the one who said it is he the
goat
right now yes he right now he's the
single best entrepreneur in the entire
world yes i agree with you is he where
does he rank in terms of history
it's hard it's a hard question
how do you think uh elon musk ranks in
terms of history
he's on mount rushmore
so top five or six yeah well top four
is only four
yeah well mount rushmore's presidents
though yeah what do you think joe um
i think he's up there for sure based on
a lot of things my whole thing with elon
musk is like
you could
not like some of the things he does
right especially within the bitcoin
community i think there's some
apprehension because he may not
understand some of the things he may not
have taken the time to learn some of the
things that people may think are
necessary
uh and he may be a proponent or pushing
other quite frankly [ __ ] coins further
right and kind of giving some of this
flood noise or uh some value but
ultimately when it comes to elon like i
never understood people that bet against
him right because he's trying to do or
like talk bad about him and all these
things because ultimately he's trying to
do really really really hard things that
if they work out will be extremely
helpful to us as a society as a planet
right and every individual that lives
here he's trying to create the ability
for us to live on multiple planets he's
trying to uh change the automobile
industry trying to change the energy
industry trying to change uh a bunch of
different industries right he he has a
million different things going on but
ultimately like my my whole thing was
just why would you ever bet against that
and i think to consider him the greatest
entrepreneur of all time like
a lot of these things we have to see how
they play out right like is he
successful with spacex on a mass scale
he's obviou he's obviously been
successful at this point he's doing a
lot of cool things but like how does
that change our life with tesla same
thing right like how does this play out
10 15 20 years down the line so i think
there's still some uh things that need
to be answered there but the things that
he's he's attacking is it's very
ambitious right i think he is he's going
after things that other people wouldn't
uh he's been successful so far but to
consider him the best entrepreneur of
all time like i think we need to see
these things play out a little further
john when you think about is there
anything that uh you think people miss
in their analysis or critiques of elon
where you're like man i just wish that
people understood this piece of it that
uh is why they're they maybe have
misplaced uh critiques yeah i think
people kind of just think elon did it
alone right he's built all these
companies by himself without any help
from anyone else or any uh predecessors
or people that came before him in the
technology space and other spaces i
think he's had a lot of help along the
way i don't think he's necessarily a
self-made man in that situation but look
i think he works hard i think he's a
marketing genius and i think he's a
really really good engineer and leader
in those companies i personally don't
think he really likes to be the ceo
would he change his title earlier this
year officially with the sec to
something but something else but the ceo
so i think that he has a lot of big
plans and i think he's executing them
very well but i think he's getting a lot
of help along the way
i agree with that i also think that uh
the story's un uh unfinished like that's
the crazy part about this is we can
evaluate like i don't know if you take
some of the best entrepreneurs in
history uh you know and uh i'll i'll
label one of these as an entrepreneur
only because i don't know what else to
label them as uh but like genghis khan
like we obviously know what the
beginning middle and end of that story
was right and so you have it kind of
like okay here's the box this is what
was produced there's a lot of good stuff
there's a lot of bad stuff in there
right so not uh not exactly the clearest
picture of like how do you evaluate
somebody like that you also have people
like let's say during the industrial
revolution so if you take somebody uh
like a john d rockefeller or andrew
carnegie right people that uh would be
assigned hey they were great in terms of
building it became some of the richest
people in the world all this stuff at
the time uh again we have the full uh
kind of story there we know here's how
they started their life here's what they
did here's how it ended here's how much
wealth they were able to accumulate
here's what they did with their wealth
once they were done right all that type
of stuff and so it's a clear kind of
evaluation of at least like hey here's
what happened and then again convoluted
story some good things some bad things
and so i think that's part of what makes
the analysis so hard with elon is that
we're still in the start i like i don't
know wait what's he like i think he's in
his early 50s that's my point like we i
think it's going to take 20 years left
yeah but we have to see how some of
these play out to consider them the
greatest of all time i think he's
certainly like on that
that path right and kind of up there
with that group but ultimately like we
have to see how how some of these pl
some of these things play out is he
greatest right now in your opinion most
influential for sure yeah uh
i just don't know who else you put up
there yeah that's built multiple
businesses this big and also i also
assigned uh that can get teams to do
things that were previously thought
impossible
like the idea of a reusable rocket
20 years ago everyone's just like oh
yeah it's expensive to launch rockets
because we only get to use them once
yeah but like we forget how fundamental
of a shift it ends up i think also in
like how much of an impact like
one it's just people love the idea of
space and rockets and stuff like that
right like of course like kids dreams to
go on rock to do these things so him
doing that obviously gives him advantage
when it comes to those things but
ultimately i think it's also like how
much does do his products and services
end up impacting consumers on a large
scale right so like tesla is a very uh
tangible asset you can look at it you
can drive it you can touch it and you
can say this is a awesome car it's
really cool i like it i like the idea
behind it it's electric all these things
helps the environment gotcha amazing
spacex like it could be similar right
we'll see kind of how that plays out uh
but ultimately i think that's a big part
of it because like if you think about
entrepreneurs um like what do you think
about uh steve jobs and wozniak like
what they did for personal computing is
is obviously super important and that's
had a massive impact on a ton of people
so i think when you think about in that
scale like those people would have to be
mentioned up there with them of course